bad things happen in small steps we have
shown you this video a couple of times
over the years and I think it's worth
showing right now because we are we're
seeing some good things happen right now
like more and more people are waking up
maybe Hamas University will collapse all
that but bad things happen in small
steps they don't just happen overnight
right the Nazis didn't just appear
overnight the actual Nazis Hitler the
actual Hitler didn't just appear
overnight it's small steps that before
you know it you look back and you go man
maybe we should have done a little
something Jordan Peterson things get to
terrible places one tiny step at a time
you know if I encroach I if I encroach
on you and I'm sophisticated about it
I'm going to encroach 2 millimet I'm
going to encroach right to the point
where you stop start to protest then I'm
going to stop then I'm going to wait
then you're going to calm down then I'm
going to encroach again right to the
point where you protest then I'm going
to stop then I'm going to wait and I'm
just going to do that forever and before
you know it you're going to be back
three miles from where you started and
you'll have done it one step at a time
and then you'll go oh how'd I get here
and the answer was well I pushed you a
little farther than you should have gone
and you agreed and so then I pushed you
a little farther than you should have
gone again and you agreed and if
anybody's interested in this sort of
process and this is a horrifying book if
you want to read about how this process
works you can read a book called
Ordinary Men by Rob you see so it
doesn't happen overnight evil doesn't
just appear overnight it festers and it
and it prays on the fact that most of us
are distracted with other things and in
modern times it's CU we're all
distracted with this so you see little
things and oh that's that's a little
weird and kid came home wearing a dress
and I guess that's a little bizarre and
they're calling for the genocide of
those people and maybe I should do
something about that what's on Netflix
tonight oh they're telling me about how
bad white people are and it just keeps
moving and moving and moving and they
push right what did I say yesterday that
it feels like we've been running through
a test over the last couple years could
we force people to live inside their
homes and tell them they can't go
outside and put masks on outside
and could we put tell people that they
can't be with their families during
Thanksgiving and that they should have
to have holidays outdoors and they can't
have parties and we'll tell people that
we're going to inject them with some
experimental thing that we have no IDE
and we all kind of did it could we tell
people that uh they don't have to follow
the law and you're actually allowed to
jump the Turn Style and you can close
down Bridges when you want so you push
push push push push push push and
eventually the systems all start
breaking down and perhaps that's where
we are right
now